hello everybody i'm delighted to
introduce professor helder
miato our first keynote speaker of this
virtual conference and sales conference
on cell and developmental biology
just a brief overview of helder helder
graduated in biochemistry and holds a
phd in biomedical sciences from the
university of porto
he was a visiting phd student at the
university of edinburgh
in the uk in the lab of bill earnshaw
and a postdoctoral research affiliate of
the new york state department of health
in the usa
in the lab of conley ryder in 2015
he was honored with the young
investigator award from the louis
chante foundation and was elected as an
embo member in 2016.
currently he is coordinating
investigator at the institute of
research and innovation
in health and the invited auxiliary
professor
with habilitation at the faculty of
medicine at the university of porto
his key to his key research interest is
the spatial temporal control of
chromosome segregation
during cell division and has been the
coordinator of two projects from the
european research council on this topic
together with his wife they founded why
science
a foundation that brings together
scientists to promote science education
and the scientific method in young
children which i know is close to both
their hearts
so now i'll hand over to helder elder
sorry to present his work
on the tubulin code
hello good morning my name is uh elder
mayato i work at the institute for
research and innovation in health and at
the university of porto
i'd like to thank the organizers for
giving me this opportunity to
present our latest work and
our it's entitled the mitotic error code
it's so of course
for uh oriented for my toes it's
aficionados but
i hope to raise your interest
as it touches many aspects of
microtubule function regulation
that i think might apply to other fields
as well
so why do we study cell division it's of
course a
fundamental process uh in our bodies
uh cells need to divide to make
multicellular organisms and
uh that's why we're here today and so to
give you an idea
uh about a trillion cell divisions take
place in in
one's body uh every day so that's a lot
of cells dividing that
we need to ensure very fundamental
functions also in
in the human adult
organism you know such as the renewal of
epithelia
our you know operating our immune system
repairing tissues etc
and if you take into account that so
many cell divisions are taking place
um and based on what we know in terms of
uh potential chromosome desegregation
events that happen
uh during cell division we can easily
uh understand that if we have
one potential misaggregation event
happening every 200 divisions and these
are based on individual
studies of course um if we could if we
do
make the math and combine these two uh
numbers one trillion cell divisions
every day and
uh one potential deleterious effect
caused by
the loss or gain of a particular
chromosome
we can easily understand that our cells
and
we as organisms live under the constant
threats of misaggregating a chromosome
and
what's the big deal about it well
it's losing or gaining chromosomes is
just the most common feature in
human cancers it's the most horizontal
property of human cancers
there's a lot of debate whether this can
uh
trigger cancer on its own but uh it's
pretty
uh consensual now that uh gain or loss
of chromosomes during cell division
and giving rise to so many
uh um chromosome aberrations in in human
cancer
it's it's really an important feature
for tumor evolution it's a very
fast way of you know evolving a cell
because all of a sudden you lose or gain
or amplify several genes
in this in a single step so you can
imagine that
you know this this is actually quite
important to understand and
based on uh world health of organization
numbers you know you can
estimate that about 10 million people
every year
die of cancer and just to give you a
comparison for for these numbers you
know
we live very different days uh you know
these days with kovid 19 and it's just
about 20 times more uh people dying from
cancer than
uh have so far died from from killing
19. so
puts the bar pretty high in terms of uh
social relevance for
understanding chromosome loss and gain
and what are the mechanisms to prevent
these to happen
and this is critical because we all know
that we not all
die from cancer despite the fact that we
are
so prone to lose or gained chromosomes
but michael is actually a very complex
system very dynamic
and here i'm illustrating a movie of a
cell dividing
where the microphotic spindle is shown
in green
expressing a gfp fusion of microtubules
and the red dots that you see
are the kinetochores the kinetochores
are the interface
between the chromosomes and the spindle
microtubules and are absolutely
essential to segregate
chromosomes during mitosis one can
easily
appreciate how orchestrated this process
has to be when we transform this movie
in two dimensions so in the
x-axis you see time and in the y-axis we
see
length and you can see that uh
the different stages of mitosis here
depicted in different colors
um the chromosomes start by meeting
all at once uh at the spindle mid zone
establishing the metaphase plate and
this process is known as chromosome
compression
and only when they congress and
establish this this position at the
equator of the cell
they are allowed to separate their
sister chromatids and migrate
quite synchronously and uniformly
towards
opposite sides of the cell giving rise
to two daughter cells that are
exactly uh or are supposedly genetically
identical
and with the exact same copy of
chromosomes as the model
um so the the topic of the talk that i
will
cover today starts with a story uh
in which we try to understand this first
stage of mitosis before the sister
chromosomes actually separate
so this point of congression at
the equator and what are the mechanisms
underlying this very fundamental
mechanism
so in a very short
summary i'm giving you the this
motorcentric view of the problem
so there's motor proteins mainly
minus and directed motors of uh you know
like dining
and plus and directed motors
from the kinesin family and one of them
is
sent to e which is a plus and directed
motor
which sits on the kinetochores
and uses pre-existing microtubules to
slide the chromosomes that are
the poles towards the equator migrating
the chromosomes to where they
should be positioned before starting
their anaphase moving towards opposite
poles
um just before i forget uh the dining
motor
uh it's also sitting at the kinetochores
but it has a
different different uh preference in
terms of direction
rather than moving cargo towards the
plus ends of the microtubules
this uh motor prefers to move the cargo
towards the minus end of the
microtubules so very close to the
where the the mitotic spindle poles here
represented by the centrosome
would be positioned then there's another
class of proteins
also from the kinesins family that
rather than sitting on the kinetochore
they actually sit on the chromosome
arms but they also have pleasant
directive activity
and they assist chromosome congression
by
participating in what is known as this
polar ejection force if you imagine
uh the mitotic spindle pole as the north
pole or south pole of our planet
so you see that the if there's what we
call polar winds
these winds will push the chromosome
arms mediated by these motors
and help assisting the congression of
these chromosomes towards the equator
so you can see that there's three main
motors involved in the process two of
them located in the
exact same position at the kinetochores
but with completely opposite activities
and then
a family of motors associated with a
chromosome arm so the question that
arose at the time was that how were
these
opposites and spatial distance
activities coordinated to drive
chromosome congratulations during
mitosis
so if we let congression depend on cmp
activity
and i'm showing you here the cell that
has been uh
treated with the center inhibitor again
you can see that most chromosomes align
and the these chromosomes remain locked
at the poles because simply it is
inhibited but then when we wash out the
inhibitor
all these chromosomes at the pole they
always always 100
of the cases they undergo motion towards
equator
and then the cell resumes uh division
however if we now uh for example replace
uh uh cmp motor at kinetochores by
a conventional kinesin so this classic
medium one
this is experiments by uh michael
lamson's lab that we were uh
we highlighted uh recently in news and
views
where they basically compare uh how
congression
is if we let the process depend on the
conventional kinesin
uh compared to the cmp canadians and
basically
the outcome was very interesting if you
let the system depend on a conventional
kinesian
the chromosomes that are at the poles
then some of them they
do migrate towards the equator but many
of them are expelled towards the cortex
and as i showed you in this previous
movie if the system
depends on fempe the chromosomes that
are at the poles
they always once you engage sample
function they
always always undergo that active motion
towards the right the correct
side where the mitotic metaphase plate
is positioned
so what's so special about senpai
that appears to know where to go
and the guide and drive these
chromosomes slowly created
um just to highlight one aspect because
i also mentioned that
these chromokinesians working on
chromosome arms
are also present and participate in
chromosomal congression
so we did one experiment to separate
this function then it was a neat
experiment because
basically we basically use a laser
microsurgery
to separate the chromosome arm which
holds
chromokinesis from the kinetochore
containing region that holds np
so these two movies that i'm going to
show you
highlight these procedures so here's the
chromosome arm
pointed out by this arrow and i'm going
to sever this arm
with a laser beam and you'll see that
when we do that there's a little
fragment here
that was loose and immediately underwent
a congression towards the metaphase
plate
so these chromosomes have these cells
have been treated with the fmp
inhibitors so you have
these chromosomes at the poles that
remain locked so
cnp's shut off and that's why these
chromosomes cannot undergo
congression but you notice that as soon
as i
released the chromosome arm from the
locked
motor uh the chromosome arm was able to
undergo directed motion and in this case
it went in the right direction
however this didn't happen in all the
cases so
i'm going to show you another example
where we're going to sever this
chromosome
arm i remind you that cmp is inhibited
in this case
so the chromosome arm now rather than
undergoing motion towards the metaphase
plate
where these chromosomes are already
aligned it will be
expelled exactly towards the cortex
exactly where we do not want to have
these chromosomes
and this give you some numbers here
uh this is what happens uh in these
experiments so cmp
uh in most cases actually is able to
undergo uh directed motion towards the
plate but there's a
significant product on cells that
actually move the chromosomes toward the
cortex
or have no movement at all and these
motion
was totally dependent on chromokinesis
because on top of it we can
we can basically inhibit or deplete
chromokinesians
uh from these cells and in this case
when we do the surgery basic chromosomes
do not under undergo any move any
movement
so this shows you this simple experiment
shows you that cmp is
dominant over chrono canadians because
if you inhibit
np you basically lock these chromosomes
for
several hours at the poles but if you
now engage
chromokinesia or you let the system
depend exclusively on chromokinesians
that work on chromosome arms
they will be able to move the
chromosomes but they do it
in a inaccurate fashion so sometimes
they will move the chromosomes towards
the cortex which is the wrong direction
so this begs the question so how does np
guide
polar chromosomes exclusive towards
equator so just to summarize
dynein is the minus then directed motor
that will bring these peripheral
chromosomes near the poles
so once at the pole then p will need to
know
where to go so how does these motors
sitting on the kinetochore
actually distinguish these uh uh
of microtubules this environment of
microtubules
where they know exactly where to go
towards the equator
what how do they know where to go
in order to to explain you this and get
into the hard
core of the the whole work experimental
work i need to introduce you
uh this notion of the tubulin code so
the tubing code
you probably have heard most people have
heard of the histone code
which basically relies on post
ventilation modifications of histones
and these regulate processes like
transcription
um and gene expression the tubulin code
on its own comprises
the combination of both tubulin isotypes
encoded by different genes
and there's many of them in in mammalian
cells
with tubulin pulse illusion
modifications and i'm
here summarizing some of them you know i
will highlight the circulation here
which happens in the
microtubule lumen but also these branch
modifications we see
terminal tails outside the globular
domains of both alpha and beta tube and
this
that corresponds to polyglot emulation
and
most important for this purpose i want
to highlight one particular modification
which is known as
uh detail organization so most alpha
tubulin isotypes
encode this last tyrosine residue over
here
so all the gene products normally have
this tyrosine at the end of the
c-terminal tail of tubulin of
off tube but there's actually catalytic
machinery that uses energy
to remove sex cells that actually bother
removing this tyrosine from some
microtubules giving rise to detoxinated
form
of tuber it's a bit of counterintuitive
that
in terms of of post solution
modification you're actually
not gaining any additional modification
you're actually
losing something that was genetically
encoded and this is known as
deterosination
um how does this deterioration
retargeting cycle
takes place so basically tubulin
in its soluble form is normally encoded
uh with this tyrosine residue on the
c-terminal tail of alpha tube
and this is uh able to be incorporated
into the polymer of
a microtubule that is that becomes
tyrosinate
but then there's a complex that was has
recently been
identified this uh tubulin
carboxypeptidase
called vasohibins bound to this
regulatory peptide
svdp that work to deteroinate
uh these last residue out of the polymer
so they seem to have a preference
although not it doesn't seem to be
excluded but have a preference
for
this tyrosinated molecules that are
incorporated into the polymer
and they're not the only players but
these are the only ones we know because
there's still some detail donation going
on
despite the fact that we could knock out
completely this vasohiben
genes there's two in in the case of
humans
so you have uh through these catalytic
action of biohumans you have
deteronated microtubules uh and then
these decarosinated tubulin could be uh
when the microtubule de-polymerizes
and it's in equilibrium with a soluble
tubulin so basically these
details in attribute can now be recycled
again
by another protein called tubulin
pyruviniligase or ttl
so this closes this deterioration
retardation cycle and
introduces the key players in the
process
but we also knew it back to the problem
that we had before
that not all microtubules in the mitotic
spindle
were identical there's actually quite
significant diversity in the spindle
namely in this case
and we know this since 1986
that only these microtubules pointing
towards the equator
uh are details innate and these normally
correspond so here i'm showing here
a more colorful picture of the process
and the detailed resonated human is
shown in green
whereas tyrosinated tubulin is shown in
white
so these white microtubules are the
astral microtubules and you can see
because they're very dynamic normally
they do not accumulate deteriorated
tubulin only the one
the microtubules pointing towards the
equator that are starting to interact
with the kinetochores here in in magenta
become details in native because they
are about 10 times more stable than all
the other microtubules in the spindle
so this provides an interesting
idea or an interesting hypothesis that
these motors
sitting here on the kinetochores on the
chromosomes that
need to be aligned to the equator could
use some
spatial cues provided by detailed
resonated microtubules
on these stable population of
microtubules that actually point
them the way to go towards the equator
so this was exactly our hypothesis you
know do decoders native microtubule
guide chromosomes during mitosis and
these are
the what what people used to think about
the spindle that despite
we knew that there are several
microtubules subpopulation
they always consider them equivalent in
the models of mitosis but we introduced
what
the ingredient that we introduced in
this model was
we introduced microtubule diversity so
if you now make
microtubules in the spindle diverse
where after my fuels for example they
are
tyrosinated and these microtubules
pointing towards the equator will be
deteronated this would explain how cnp
at the poles would be able to move
chromosomes exclusively towards the
equator
and we could add some prediction so if
we inhibit
the carboxy peptidase activity necessary
to
determinate uh microtubules so you
render
all your microtubules tied organized
basically this would
phenocopy the inhibition of the motor
because the motor once
the chromosome gets stuck at the poles
they will not be able to move towards
the equator because they missed the
spatial cue that shows them
where to go on the other hand if we now
render
the the the spindle uh essentially
highly detailed innate and we can do
that by depleting the
ttl protein that recycles the
tyrosinated curing so all your
microtubules will be decalasinated so
the chromosomes
uh because the motor that that guy that
usually guides them
uses these detail designation uh track
details needed tracks
the motor could now in principle move
across something random that actually
sure enough they will bring some towards
the equator but many of them will
be expelled towards the wrong directions
pretty much as chromokinesians did
when we let the system rely on them
exclusively
and so this is just to show you that we
can actually efficiently
uh deplete ptl by multiple means and i'm
showing here
rnai experiment but we can do also uh
crispr
knockouts on the protein cells are
actually viable
and these corresponds to an increase in
beta resonated tube and as expected
okay with no much change in the tidal
eliminated level of tubing which
composes
most of the micro of fueling in the cell
we could also inhibit tubulin carboxy
peptide activity with this drug called
partenolite
which basically blocks this
sits right here on the catalytic triad
of these
carboxy peptidase preventing
its propaganda activity and therefore
preventing
human detoxination activity
just to show you what we see in cells so
pretty much
these movies are running in parallel and
you can see here that the paternal light
when we inhibit the carboxy peptidase
basically phenocopies the inhibition of
the motor
so we we end up in a situation where
most chromosomes
are able to align but the some
chromosomes
get stuck at the poles because they
basically
uh uh they are unable to find the
the spatial q that guides them towards
the equator so they still copy
the inhibition of the motor on the other
hand the depletion of ptl
um also in this case compromises
compression a bit
then you can see that these chromosomes
they are no longer clustered at the
poles as
you see here in the semi-inhibited cell
or the parthenology but it gets
scattered
uh around the poles being expelled
towards
the cortex you can have a close-up look
into this uh
pole then you can basically confirm here
that the inhibition of the motor
or inhibition of tubulin determination
uh phenocopies the clustering of these
chromosomes that gets stuck at the poles
and are unable to go to
anywhere in fact but tpl the patient
instead does not cluster the chromosomes
and they now
are able to migrate in all directions
including towards the cortex
and these random motion can be uh is
essentially centrally dependent because
it can significantly rash to it
by co-depleting or co-inhibiting in this
case uh the cmp motor
so basically this tells you that uh
either inhibiting the motor
or the modification that the motor uses
on the tracks that takes the motor in
this case the chromosome as well
towards the equator uh are are
informed we provide cues spatial cues
that orient the motor
towards the right direction
so how do we test this uh in a
simplified manner so how do we test this
idea that the motor
indeed is reading these cues so we we
use
purified uh details in nato tubing or
title genetic tube and that we extract
from the human healer cells and we did
this in collaboration with
magda madeira and carton yankees curie
in paris
and and purified the cmp motor domain
and tagged it with gfp so we can see
this uh
centipede molecule in green
and you can see here the different types
of microtubules so the deteriorating
microtubules will show up
in pink or magenta and the tyrosinated
enriched microtubules will be shown here
in red
and the green dots that you see here are
the motor
single molecules of these senti motors
walking along these microtubules and
they're going to see
that they are able to ride these
microtubules towards the
plus ends but if you have a good eye and
look carefully
the velocities on the details of native
microtubules the pink ones are faster
and this is calculated here
so this motor is actually more efficient
motor on decathlon technique
microtubules
and they're able to run significantly
increased lengths
if the microtubules are detoxinated or
if it's enriched in details native
tubing
as compared to microtubules enriched for
tyrosinated tube
we could then apply force on these
motors by coupling these
motors to beads so these beads can be
trapped
on a optical trap an infrared laser
basically
and position the longer microtubule that
has a minus n and a plus end
this is shown here and as we
as the motor tries to move across
the microtubule it will exert force so
basically we can measure
how efficient is these beads that are
trapped by the laser
can you can try to escape the force that
is
uh unbeing undertaken by the
by the by the optical trap and the
typical experiment looks like this i'm
going to show you here the microtubule
shown in red there's a bead
on top of it there's a green signal
coming out of gfp
coding the bead and you will see that
the bead will now show up only and the
bead
will start wobbling and will basically
trying to escape
the optical trap and you can measure
these excursions
uh and these are shown here in these two
graphs and these are this is the titles
initial tubulin microtubule then you can
have these spikes
of activity but if you do that on
decodated
like a tuba basically the spikes are
much higher meaning that you need to
experience much higher force to
counteract
the loss of the bead
and the duration of spikes are also
is also significantly higher
so in other words these
beads are able to detach out of these
microtubules
easier if they are on
tyrosinated microtubules so
you need a
much
they need much higher force
to have these
beats detaching out of these
microtubules as opposed
if they are traveling on titanosaunated
microtubules meaning that
they are more efficient motors
at transporting these beads along these
microtubules
along in this case uh deterozonated
microtubules so
in summary so this slide shows that we
can reconstitute
cmp mediated volatility in vitro and
compare
its efficiency along tyrosinated
enriched or detailed resonated enriched
microtubules and we show here
that centi is a much efficient
motor um on traveling along
detail donated microtubules so this gave
us a hint and a direct
point to look at at this in uh
live cells again and here i'm showing
the cell that is expressing uh
microtubules in red
and sempi and in green with gfp
and cmp and interface cells also
decorate microtubules and it looks like
this so
if we basically treat these cells with
dnso which is a
solvent that we use for these
experiments
so you can see that the cmp holds on
pretty tight on microtubules over time
but if we now do the same experiment
uh inhibiting tubulin carboxy peptide
activity you can see here
that microtubules again are in red and
here simply even green
see what happens just in a matter of a
few minutes
the microtubules remain the center
completely detaches
out of these microtubules so uh by
changing the details designated
state of these microtubules in cells
you can change the ability of cnp to in
this case accumulate on microtubules
further supporting the our individual
reconstitution data
so all together we proposed a model in
which
uh a tubulin deterioration works like a
navigation system for chromosomes
so if you have a system that relies uh
on these uh modifications in and you
inhibit
deep uh detonation uh crumbs will be
locked at the poles but if we now
inhibit
uh make all the microtubules decalinated
uh the motor that reads these cues
basically will go
in all directions so during normal
division
we have a mix of microtubules we have
microtubule diversity
and these different tracks can be used
to regulate
different motors to allow them to find
their way towards the equator
so how do i get
how do we get into this idea of mitotic
error code so this was
our way in into the tubulin codes and
their roles in micros and now i'm going
to show you
uh the latest part of our work that just
that just that was just published a few
weeks ago that looks at the role of
deteronation in other aspects of mitosis
and indeed so just to point out that uh
this idea of tabling code and navigation
system might actually
um uh uh you know be a
real idea uh it was later
confirmed that the other opposing motor
dinin dynactin
actually preference as a preferential
movement
uh along titles in native microtubules
so the two
the two motors that sit at the
kinetochore
and pull on different directions
basically have distant preferences for
these microtubules
modificate microtubule modifications
dynadyne acting prefers tidal related
microtubules
whereas nt prefers detailed resonated
microtubules
and this is how we think that the market
tube will use these modifications
to regulate the activity of different
motors in this case
uh sitting on the same uh
structure on the chromosome the
kinetochore
so what are the aspects of mitosis which
are regulated by the tubulin code and
basically
we know that about uh there's not just
one canadian like protein in mitosis
there's about
12 medium-like proteins that have been
described to play a role in mitosis
so it's pretty uh reasonable to
hypothesize that
other aspects of mitosis might be
regulated by the tubulin code
by affecting these other motors
involving different mitotic processes
and one motor in particular that i want
to bring to your attention
is actually not a classic motor so it's
a kinetic protein protein
that rather than moving cargo along
microtubules
uses the energy derived from atp
hydrolysis
to disassemble to promote or disassemble
or depolymerize
a microtubule and this was shown several
years ago
by the group of annie andrea and more
recently by the
group of bronzer that canadian 13s
are negatively regulated by detailed
vention
so they actually are much uh better
microtubule deep polymerizing motors
if they have to work on uh
tyrodinated uh tube and rather than
details like the tubing as opposed to
cmp
as i explained before so this gives us a
suggestion that a very important aspect
of mitosis
concerning error correction might be
regulated by the treatment code because
one of these canadian 13s encak is
actually
one of its favorite locations it's on
the centromere
and being at the centromere it can
actually
use these capacity to depolymerize
microtubules
to correct erroneous attachments so this
activity would be there
to prevent this kind of uh incorrect
attachments in which a single
kinetochore is attached to microtubules
from both poles
and therefore these wrong attachments
should be destabilized and it's
believed to be uh undertaken by
the reaction of these mcac proteins
sitting on the centromeres
and therefore when they all the tasks
are corrected
you can have successful segregation but
if you have um
ncac activity compromised these
these iranians attachments go
unsupervised
and undetected then they cannot be
corrected
and this leads to several types of
chromosome desegregation events
we think by
compromising the mcat field so we
hypothesized that these processes
of error correction uh involving mcac
could be regulated by human
determination
and to address this uh lisa freida in
our lab
uh started investigating the
accumulation of decarbonated tubulin
on different types of kinetic or
microtubule attachments and to do that
she converted the spindles in multiple
configurations here's a
what we call a monopolar spindle
configuration which we can
trigger by inhibiting kinesin 5 with
this
small molecule inhibitor called
monostrol and this gives rise to these
incorrect types of attachments called cp
leak attachments in which both
kinetochores are attached to a single
pole or
incomplete or immature attachments in
which a single kinetochore
is attached to a microtubule so it's
called monophylic attachment
and here on the gray panels you have
the accumulation of detail resonated
tubulin on these microtubules and you
can see
it's pretty faint on these
but if you now compare this signal
with a signal that we normally obtain
when the microtubules are
when the spindle is bipolar and the
chromosomes are bi-oriented
you can see that native tubing also
accumulates
precisely on the microtubules pointing
towards the equator as i showed before
and this is even exacerbated if we now
hyperstabilize these microtubules with
this drug called taxol
so i give you some numbers so indeed a
chromosome that is bi-oriented has a
much
higher deteronated tubulin level
very close to the kinetochore so we're
measuring here
in the very uh close vicinity of the
kinetico within one micron distance
along the kinetochore microtubules
from the kinetochore as compared in this
case to
a condition in which the attachments are
not fully matured or are incorrect
and this is exacerbated as i told you by
uh treatment of those
cells with uh with these microtubules
probabilizing drugs so we have
here um uh in a quantitative
manner uh an indication that different
types of attachment
have different types of or accumulate
different levels of detailed resonated
tubulin with more stable attachments on
a bipolar configuration
being enriched for deteriorated tubers
so then we asked whether what are the
consequences
of having microtubules decal generated
and to do that we basically deplete uh
ttl from the cells and and if you
see careful here you can see that if we
deplete ttl from the cell
all your microtubules suddenly become
detailed in it
including these tiny little actual
microtubules that are normally
not detailed generated
and then so we basically conservatively
increased
the human detail resonation in the cell
and up what is the
the consequence for chromosome
segregation
and here i'm showing two movies the
control cell
in which you have the green dots
revealing the chromosome position of the
kinetochore in this case
and here is what happens in tpl the
tweet itself
so the chromosomes have a hard time
compressing but they
eventually manage to align but i hope
you notice that some of these green dots
actually lag behind so i'm going to play
this again
and i hope you appreciate
that right here you have these
tiny little dots of chromosomes that lag
behind
and this is very frequent in these ttl
depleted cells
so if you compare here in these
pool from three different independent
experiments
it seems that if you render microtubules
consideratively detail
the native that causes problems in
either error correction or you actually
make the cells more prone
to make errors
we actually investigated these deeper
by using by super resolution microscopy
this is a modified version of stead
microscopy
which we called coherent hybrid steps
method that was developed by antonio
preda
in our lab where we can very easily
track uh microtubules at very high
resolution and invest again
look how these chromosomes that are
lagging behind look like
and in fact you can see that the
kinetico region here in red
is actually stretched then you have
microtubules ending from both sides
indicating that this incorrect
conformation called merotylic attachment
is actually taking place and explaining
why you have so many chromosomes lagging
behind
when we perturb ptl activity or when we
make
uh microtubules constitutively uh
deteriorated
just forgot to mention so in we did one
experiment in which
you you it's called the monastery
washout experiment so we treat cells
with each drug
monastral the chromosomes become
uh mono-oriented because these spindles
are monopolar um and we can now release
these cells from monothrow allowing
the cells to become bio-oriented
and if you see these numbers so uh
if you compare and treated cells with
monasterial treatment cells
you can see that both control and ptl
depleted cells increase and they
increase in the same proportion
suggesting that you're not increasing
the rate of
error formation by depleting ttl
so this difference here is either being
caused by a
problem or a compromised error
correction process
and here to substantiate these
experiments
we actually measured whether centrosome
separation at the beginning of mitosis
is normal uh in ttl depleted cells
because if you
abolish centrosome separation or it
delays understand separation
early in mitosis you make the cells
prone to establish
iranian attachments and uh so it's a
clearly error formation
pathway that becomes activated
if you don't separate centrosomes and
then
if you can see the centrosome separation
is absolutely normal with or without ttl
so we don't think that indeed increased
determination
is contributing to erroneous
attachments because they fall more often
it's rather the opposite
the correction becomes more compromised
and i need to introduce you to
the models of how people perceive error
correction takes place and there's
basically two
main models with a clear dominant one
which is highlighted now in the screen
so basically error correction takes
place by
promoting kinetochore microtubule
turnover and there's a sort of sweet
spot
in which kinetochore microtubule
half-life is just
right to basically allow
the satisfaction of the spindle assembly
checkpoint which
monitors the attachments of microtubules
to kinetochore
but on the other hand uh prevents the
hyperstabilization
of the attachments which could lead to
chromosomal instability that i alluded
to in the beginning of the talk so this
would be
taking place on all kin air court in a
non-discriminatory
manner so that the eventual mistakes
will get corrected after some time and
chromosome segregation could take place
normally
there's also additional views
that are perceived as discriminatory
for example this protein aurora b
and also mcat that i told you about so
orbeez the
central player in error correction in
mitosis
uh as as it is mcac in fact orbeez
able to regulate temp activities through
phosphorylation because it's a protein
kinase
so it you can actually found these two
proteins mcac
and rrb here enriched
on erroneous attachments so it does
suggest that
the cell is able to sense in some way
where iranian attachments are and
recruit the factors to these places or
enrich
in these places to allow for efficient
error correction
so if our uh results with detail
resonation
was were uh causing errors
by changing microtubule stability
so the discriminant in this case the
non-discriminatory
model that i referred to
we would expect to see changes in
kinetic or microtubule half-life after
depleting ptl
so we do that by photo activating
gfp tubulin on a cell that stably
expresses
and cherry tube so you can see nicely
the spindle here
and then we basically photo activate the
stripe
of gfp alpha tubulin and
measure the dissipation of fluorescence
over time
and that gives you a quantitative view
of the turnover or half-life of
the kinetochore microtubules in these
cells because we can extract this
out of these decay curves taking into
account this very slow recovery
component here
shown in this graph and you can see that
if we
do that there's basically not much
changes uh between controls
uh in si or ttl depleted cells both in
prometaphase or metaphase
so this basically tells you gives you an
idea of the estimated
number of microtubules in both
conditions
but most importantly if you look at
kinetochore afterlife
as expected in control cells the
stability of magnetic will decrease
as cells transit from prometaphase this
early mitotic condition to metaphase
when they become bio-oriented where the
chromosomes become by oriented
but there's no difference no measurable
difference when we deplete
ttl out of these cells so we're having
more
errors without globally changing kinetic
or microtubule half-life
and what is interesting is that indeed
if we completely deplete
mtac from the cell you do see an
increase in
kinetochore microtubule half-lives
the kinetico microtubule stability when
cells are devoid of
impacts specifically during metaphase so
these two results are
a bit difficult to integrate
because okay mcac is involved in our
correction and as expected
it does have a role in kinetico
microtubule half-life when we deplete
its entire pool but ttl
doesn't seem to act through these
pathways
because it doesn't change kinetic or
microtubule the half-life
another aspect that is here is that
indeed ptl
depleted cells accumulate determinated
tubulin
precisely on kinetochore microtubules
here illustrated in this panel but mcac
depletion
accumulates deteronated human
essentially on
iso microtubules so the overall
depletion of the total pool of van [ __ ]
in the cell
preferentially affects the stability
of astro microtubules as opposed to
in this case the depletion of the sit tl
and the pattern of detail of the nation
is completely different between these
two scenarios
so it's not going to be that the ttl and
it's the
the increase in microtubule detail of
the nation is uh
causing an impact on overall impact
activity
so there's still something to understand
between the relationship between
tubulin deterioration and ncac but what
is curious that if we over express
if we give the cells more copies of mcat
or increase or enhance its activity with
a small molecule
agony umk57 you're
able to rescue the increase in the
lagging chromosomes or the iranians
attachments in this case
in cells depleted of pto so you should
see look at this bar
here where we deplete ttl we basically
rescue the percentage of errors by
over expressing jfp and cac
or enhancing its activity so somehow
there's some link between uh increased
decarbonation
and impact activity that we do not fully
understand
so to dissect this we basically used
different mcat mutants and asked about
their efficiency in rescuing the ptl
depleted cells
so i'm showing here the full length and
cac so he she has his motor domain here
and the kinetochore binding domain is
here on the n terminus
and we have uh basically a a dead
version of these d polymerase so it
lacks the polymerase activity it's
called this
encock high pure motor and also this
delta
n concert which prevents mk
to go to the kinetochore and
two other constants here basically
competitively target
amcac exclusively to the centromere so
you can follow this
localization here you can see nicely
localization
of mcac exclusively on the centromeres
here
um and we also have a dead version of
this
construct that we constitutively target
to the centromeres by fusing with the
this consistent protein send b
so we use these different targeting
these different
mutant constructs to ask about their
efficiency in rescuing uh
the increase in chromosomes miser
irrigation due to
conservative uh increase in microtubule
determination so as expected so the full
length
gfp mcac rescues to some extent
the errors the anaphase errors observed
after ptl depletion
but if you and this is dependent on the
deep polymerizing activity so if you
have a catalytic diversion
there's basically no effect on no no
rescue effect
due to increased deterioration and
if you lack the capacity to go to the
centromeres or kinetochores you also are
unable to
rescue these mistakes so you need both
depolymerizing activity
and kinetochore centromere localization
to allow
the rescue of error correction observing
ttl depleted cells
and most important this seems to be
sufficient also for these refs so if you
target these
mcac to the centromeres you efficiently
rescue
to a certain extent the errors observed
in ptl deplete itself
and again this is absolutely dependent
on its catalytic activity
so in in short and correctly
polymerizing activity at centromeres is
required and sufficient
to significantly rescue error correction
due to high
microtubule deterioration after ttl
depletion
and consistent with this uh idea
the effect that we see when we over
express mcac full length
over spindle length or astral
microtubule length is quite
notorious so if you globally change the
activity of this protein you do affect
spindle length and astronomical length
because you affect
globally microtubule dynamics but this
construct here the gcp bm
which was able to rescue the errors
observed in ppl the plate itself
has no effect on overall spindle length
or astral microtubule length
again suggesting that the way
that this concept is rescuing or reading
the determinated state
of microtubules is very localized
particularly the centromere it doesn't
affect or you don't
or it doesn't involve other pools of the
mcat
present in other parts of the spindle
like those microtubule plasmas or
atheromic
tables and in fact this kinetochore
market you
can do basically the same experiment
that we as we did before measuring the
kinetico microtubule half-life
in cells that conservatively expressed
the gcpdm
construct and we find no effect on
no change in kinetico molecule stability
in metaphase compared to control
cells so basically the market you will
adopt
a similar kinetico microtubule half-life
between prometaphase and metaphase when
we express this construct
and this is no different from the
stability that we normally observe
in metaphase so we don't think that
deteronation is globally impairing ncac
function
but it's specifically impairing a
fraction or a pool of vent calc at the
centromeres
so we put this into a model and we like
to call
refer this model to the mitotic error
code which is the title of
this presentation and basically to
summarize this last part of the work
we envisioned that microtubules and the
types of attachments that occur in the
cells
um are quite different and early on when
the attachments are immature or
incorrect
microtubules will essentially be
tyrosinated
and titanated tubulin will promote
uh uh or will be favored
microtubule deep polymerase activity by
amtak at centromeres
contributing to the destabilization of
these attachments so it's part of this
feedback
loop that goes on at the centromeres so
this will contribute to the detachment
or declinarization of these microtubules
and eventually the cell will reach the
desired configuration
the bio-orientator or amphetalic
conformation
and as they become bi-oriented as we
showed uh
microtubule details in nation
accumulates in the kinetochore vicinity
and this works as a negative feedback so
it basically
prevents uh the ongoing or
continuing activity of the of mk at
centromeres because details native
children
inhibit its activity and this would
further stabilize the attachments
favoring this configuration that is
correct so you have
cytosine the tubulin on incorrect
determination
on correct and moreover this mechanism
would explain
how the cell avoids further
meropelic attachments as
uh and avoids the incursion of
new microtubules that will try to make
an error
so if you have a configuration of
bi-oriented uh
microtubules whether the kinetochores
with the
high detailed native tumor and the new
microtubule
that is more dynamic and therefore uh
accumulates
hydrogenated tubulin the cell will be
able to selectively
destabilize these incorrect attachments
and maintain the correct ones this
allowing for the discrimination
of the types of attachments favoring
these configurations right here
so when this is consideratively high so
the determinate state is considerably
high so the cells
enter mitosis with high details native
level
the process of error correction is is
not allowed to occur at high efficiency
so the cor
the attachments that are incorrect will
not be solved
and they will produce the cell
eventually contributing to
uh uh chromosomal instability and this
work
um was recently published in jcb so if
you're curious
you're more than welcome to visit uh
this paper and and uh and i'll be happy
here
uh to uh also uh follow up with with
some
uh discussion um so with this i'd like
to thank
uh the people that did the work and
particularly luisa
and as we speak lisa freda
just graduated defended her thesis
a couple of hours ago so congratulations
to her
and for completing this work
and also i'd like to thank marine bodies
it's a former post clock in the lab
that uh to uh initiated
uh uh the work with chilean
modifications in our lab and now has his
own lab in copenhagen several
collaborators for
the help in study and for reagents
people from my lab these agencies
for funding and you for your attention
and i'll be happy to take questions so
thank you very much
um i'd just like to thank elder for his
fantastic presentation
uh it was a certainly a very
comprehensive series of
experiments leading to his model the
error code model
um there was a fantastic combination
very interesting combination of
obviously very high resolution
microscopy backed up by the molecular
biology
with using the various inhibitors and
and rnai's so
very very nice serious experiments thank
you elder
so i'd like to now move on to some
questions that have come in
so the first question i have is
i would like to ask if the beads would
not have any effect or hindrance to the
migrating microtubules
do the beads have negligible mass and
would not
affect the displacement i think this
refers to earlier in your presentation
elder
okay thank you um well that's a very
good question but um
indeed we the beads are exactly the same
in both conditions so
the mass is not going to be negligible
so these are polystyrene uh
beads um they are both coated with the
motor
and the difference in this experiment
the variable that is
uh changed um is essentially
the enrichment in details innate tubing
or
tidals in attitude so we have
microtubules
that are enriched for one modification
or the other the beads are the same
and they are both coated with snp motors
fused with gfp and we just
measure the displacement of the bead
and out of the optical trap
so it wouldn't really matter uh in this
case
uh because the beads are are are
stereotypical so they're exactly
they're exactly the same in both
experimental conditions so what changes
are the the microtubules that are
gliding on
um and these can be measured uh using
the optical trap that are cut that are
calibrated
i hope this answers the question
so the next question um are there any
studies about the inhibition of
microtubule
detyrosization in cancer cells and does
the mite
the microtubule do type the tyranite
detainerization
inhibition uh is it a good potential to
target
for cancer cells that's a very
interesting question
it has been shown that the details in
nation
is is a frequent occurrence in some
types of of cancer and
it is also used uh for
prognostic reasons in the uh
people you know uh tumors with high
tubulin deterioration actually have
a poor prognosis and it's also known
that the
suppression of this key enzyme tubulin
tyrosine ligase
occurs during tumor growth so it seems
that
for a tumor to develop and and and
grow you need to
suppress these stimulants in ligase
activity therefore
uh leading to increase in
tubulin details in asia and there's some
inhibitors
of tubulin deterioration that are
actually used
used already in the clinics um so
there's one
the one that i mentioned partenolide
it's a it's a natural product that is
used
uh or has been used in in some
cancer studies it's not really uh
already
uh used in the clinics but is uh
pre-clinical studies
and they seem to have a good potential
effect
stress in combination with other drugs
using in chemotherapy
that prevent tumor growth so
it might be a good strategy since you
need detoxination to take place for a
tumor to develop
it might be a good strategy indeed to
suppress
uh tubulin detailed ozonation there's
now more specific and more
uh powerful inhibitors of human
uh the stimulant carbohydrate peptides
that take place
in the under undertake tubulin details
nation so it's a very
promising avenue that is still
pretty much underdeveloped
and deserves with you know higher
attention in the future
so thank you elder for next question
what determines the accumulation of a
specific
tubulin post-trans uh post-translation
modification
on a given population of microtubules
wow that's a wonderful question and um
it's
uh indeed it's probably a combination of
factors
one key factor is microtubule stability
if your microtubules are short-lived
they will not have
time to accumulate specific tube and
post relation modifications
so you need to have a certain
[Music]
you know stability so the microtubule
has to be
long-lived so that you start
accumulating some
modifications in particular the one i
mentioned today
determination but this is also the case
for others
the other key element is where are the
enzymes located and this is still
hill explored in the and and deserves
for the tension
because only recently we we
knew which enzymes actually account for
these uh specific positive modification
so it's a relatively new field
the enzymes became known only for a few
years
and um and determining where they
localize and what determines
uh the localization of the enzymes one
particular microtubule
subpopulations would also help
explaining
why only a given population of
microtubules accumulates a particular
modification but i would go
with the first explanation that
microtubule stability is certainly a key
uh
factor to that determines that the
microtubule will be
uh post relationally modified
okay and there's just one final question
before we before we wrap
up and that is how do tubulin
post-translation
modifications combine to control
function
that's another excellent question
um we are only starting to understand
how individual potential modifications
regulate particular functions how
the the the real
concept of the tubulin code which which
relies on the combination
of multiple postulation modifications
together with tubing isotypes
how this all combination of
modifications
translates into function it's one of the
uh
uh you know most important
open questions in the field and and we
don't have an answer yet
but now with the our understanding of
uh the mechanisms and the enzymes
involved we could
envision that we could combine
individual or
multiple perturbations of multiple
enzymes
involved in different positive
modifications so that we can understand
the power of the modifications and also
take advantage of the super resolution
techniques to
map how the different postulation
modifications
add to one another and combine on a
particular microtubule
to eventually regulate function so it's
uh it's going to be
[Music]
an open question for some time and
we hope to participate in obtaining some
of these answers
okay so well thank you very much for um
attending this
first um invited speaker webinar
on this event um so very much appreciate
you joining us
and thank you again to elder miato for
his presentation
and we hope that you get to enjoy the
rest of this virtual event over the next
couple of days thank you very much